chuckle how do you give feedback to
someone without everyone taking it
personal I try to give criticism
regarding their work or actions while
not attacking their character but
unfortunately many feel that it's
personal yeah welcome to the world
people don't like chrism criticism and I
almost put eight no one in the world
like scripts okay so there might be
point zero zero zero zero one percent of
the world that's really like open and
ready for feedback right but most people
even when they say even when they tell
you they want feedback they don't want
it they don't want it like let me let me
give an example if you echo Charles yes
we're like you made a video and it took
you an hour don't even write you know
like you could come to me and say hey
what do you think you know and I was
like well you know I think you framed
this up wrong how what's your reaction
to that I mean there's no possible way
that you're stoked on that they're just
now luckily you know we know each other
you can detach me be like all right I
need you he doesn't he's not pointing
this out to me for no reason whatever
but what I'm saying is even when you're
saying hey what do you think of this and
I criticize something that you work so
hard on there's no one in the world
that's happy about that even when they
asked for it
mmm-hmm so you have to flank people
that's what you have to do now he's
asking specifically how do you do this
so here's some things what one of the
things that I do when I want to give
someone Chris's my don't give him
criticism what I do is I ask them
questions about whatever it is now he
this is interesting
I'm not even talking about pointed
questions I'm not even talking about
like hard questions I'm talking I'm not
saying like why did you do that you know
I'm talking about hey why did you do it
that way
like there's a big difference between
like hey why did you do it that way yeah
like instead of saying hey echo that
frame it doesn't look good hey why'd you
frame that up like that mmm right so now
I'm getting you to think about it right
but I'm not gonna say do how are you to
make that work mmm you know I'm gonna
say well hey do you think you're gonna
be able to make that work
if if you did something and it doesn't
go well I'm not gonna say you know did
you actually think that was a good idea
instead I'm gonna say it's again it's
not pointing question let me say well
hey did that unfold the way you thought
it was gonna unfold and you know you're
gonna get to answer the question now
you're gonna be the you're gonna be the
person that uncovers the fault it's
gonna be you not me and that makes it so
much more palatable to everyone when
they're able to say oh yeah you know I
saw this over here
and most the time the person knows the
truth most of the time the person knows
that that thing's not framed up right
they know that their idea was not great
so you don't need to punch him in the
face with it cuz that's actually gonna
make him get defensive
so you flank him you ask him the
questions you talk about it you discuss
the subject and what you do is you guide
them you guide them to a mirror you
guide them to a mirror and then and then
you look at that bear mm-hmm you set
them up so they have to look in that
mirror so that they can see the problems
themselves and once they see the
problems themselves they can start to
correct them now sometimes you sometimes
it's your ego that wants even once they
see the problem themselves do people
want them to take credit for showing
that misleads you you got to check your
ego you got to make sure that your ego
isn't saying I want to prove to this
person that I know how to frame this up
better then you got to put that all in
check and you gotta just let you're
gonna let them have it so now are there
situations where you can give really
good frank feedback yes there is but you
have to have a good relationship for
that person a really good really good
relation if that person and then usually
one of the best ways to to make this
happen is that the feedback the negative
feedback is going both ways meaning I
want to get negative feedback about my
performance from that person so that
there's some equanimity in what's being
said amongst us right so I might be
little you know I might say hey echo hey
man I I you know I did this uh I answer
this question on Q&A did you think that
was a good answer because I think you
know I think could have been better and
you say yeah you know you dragged on you
talk too long and whatever you give me
some critique and then I go oh yeah hey
and by the way the lighting on that
didn't look good right and so now we
have a little mutual criticism and it's
all good it makes a little bit more
palatable to you because I made the
thing and so that sometimes works but
what's interesting is even when you do
that some people just don't even
freaking care and and they even after
they just tear you apart and then you
throw a little little like a little nick
on their shoulder on their an arm you
give them a little nick about something
that wasn't right they still get so you
have to be really you have to have a
really great relationship with that
person to be able to have just that
straight straight feedback but build
relationships ask them questions let
them find their own fault if you can and
be their guide let them guide them to
that mirror got into their faults now of
course there are some people that won't
even find their own faults no matter how
you guide them and how hard you try and
twist them to look in the mirror you
have to let them know you actually have
to come out and say what's going on you
have to be more direct now luckily if a
person is the type of person that fails
to see their own faults they begin to
fail right because they're making
mistakes that's why their faults right
they're making mistakes and when they
see that when you see that and you see
that their project is failing or you see
that their people are revolting against
them or you see that they're missing
deadline after deadline they know that
too and then what you're doing is you're
coming to them basically as like a
concerned friend that really wants to
help them win and and pointing out some
of these obvious failures that they
might not be you know aware of and you
still got to be gentle about this hmm
but when you come to them you can come
to them as a friend as a as a person
that really wants them to win you can
come out out of there looking like the
good guy trying to help them get there
their self back on track so those are
some of the
some of the basic strategies and I used
to help people do a little course
correction if people need a little
criticism so that they can improve their
game for themselves for the team etc
people are people aren't people aren't
people own like criticism yeah her to
tell you yeah they like praise you know
how and you know the other side of this
coin if you're a person which you are
and you don't like christen what you
don't if you can open your mind to the
criticism man you're gonna be so you're
gonna get so much better about
everything that you do if you can just
listen to people about getting ego crazy
and thinking about this yep this list
you just listen nod your head listen to
what they have to say they're trying to
help you yeah right we assume that
they're trying to help us yeah listen to
I don't know oh yeah are there times
they're not absolutely yeah you're going
with the assumption that this person's
just trying to cut me down well that's
not gonna get you anywhere yeah but if
you if you make this something you know
what I'm gonna listen to what this
person has to say what's wrong with that
yeah even if it's an assumption and
we're not supposed to assume if I
assumed he'd give me one I'm gonna
assume that echos giving me criticism
right now cuz he wants me to do better
and I'm gonna take them as as face value
as I can yeah that he is trying to help
me get better you know
yeah and yeah that's actually really
correct if you start at that point
that's your default right hey this
criticism is to help now I might look at
your criticism and I analyze it from a
detached perspective and I go I think
actually echo is just trying to drag me
in the wrong place and I might get to
that point yeah and it'll be more way
more obvious it'll be way more via if
you started at that other place okay but
if you're just default all he just wants
to try to look like he knows everything
he just wants to you know make if you
start higher place to this yeah you
can't even kind of discern you know if
that really is happening or not not the
place to be another place did me